contre cette proposition projet de loi
le droit à l'avortement est un droit
dans notre société et je ne suis pas du
tout hostile j'y suis favorable
en revanche pensent que la liberté
d'expression est aussi un droit et je ne
vois pas au nom de quoi on peut
commencer à grimper dans la
désinformation qui va décider de la
désinformation
ça devient une société totalitaire et
j'estime que on met le main la main dans
un engrenage
je suis pas d'accord avec madame keller
je comprends ce qu'elle dit la douleur
ceux des situations très délicates mais
il ya plein de sites d'information qui
explique très bien ce que celle ivg de
manière très correcte et toute personne
peut s'informer mais ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'on va commencer à voter
des lois qui créent des oukases
on n'a pas le droit de regarder tel site
ou tel si vous pensez que ça veut dire à
l'avortement n'est pas menacée en france
et vous ne redoutez pas que certaines
candidats veuillent et avenir en jeu en
tout cas je pense que c'est un droit
reconnu de tous
et là il faudra ce match il y avait le
danger mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on vote des lois d'opinion c'est
une wag opinion c'est une loi
d'interdiction d'opinion et on va aller
jusqu'où alors après il y aura un autre
sujet je suis pour le droit à
l'avortement
bien évidemment j'aurais toujours voté
ces lois mais pour autant il ya le droit
à la liberté d'expression dans notre
pays
est-ce que je devrais ce que c'est une
très grave dérive est-ce que vous
toucherez par exemple aux subventions
des associations georges sur toutes ces
questions je pense qu'on a trouvé un
équilibre dans notre société et
j'aimerais qu'on renforce en revanche
les sites d'information pour la
contraception